con un agradecimiento a España por la
ayuda bélica política y humanitaria ya
brindada el ministro de defensa
ucraniano o lexir resnikov insistió en
la necesidad que aún existe en su país y
es que según resnikov cuando la guerra
está en tu casa siempre hay escasez y
por eso durante la conferencia de prensa
que dieron los encargados de defensa de
España y Ucrania tras su reunión en
Madrid el ministro ucraniano pidió como
prioridad más sistemas antiaéreos más
munición de artillería y seguir
recibiendo la ayuda técnica y formación
por parte del personal español por su
lado la ministra de defensa española
Margarita Robles aseguró que España
siempre ayudará en la medida de sus
posibilidades
esta reunión sucedió a escasos días de
que se envíen los primeros seis tanques
leopar y otros 20 blindados españoles
que llegarían a suelo ucraniano a
finales de abril en el primer año de
guerra se calcula que la ayuda militar
procedente de España ascendió a 320
millones de euros la financiera a 3 50
millones y la ayuda humanitaria a 50
millones de euros ambos ministros
negaron de manera rotunda también que
haya personal militar de la otan en
Ucrania información que aparecía en los
documentos clasificados de Estados
Unidos que fueron filtrados hace unos
días según el funcionario ucraniano hay
una mezcla de información verídica y de
información falsa pero la verídica ya no
está actualizada para Red y Robles la
filtración es un intento de dividir a
los aliados y de beneficiar a Rusia